u.s climate envoy john kerry not making
president biden look look good after
saying biden had no idea his submarine
deal with the uk and australia would
upset the french government
he asked me he said what's the situation
and i explained exactly
he was he had not been aware of that he
literally literally had not been aware
of what had transpired and i don't want
to go into the details of it but suffice
it to say
that
that the president um
my president is very committed
to um
strengthening the relationship and
making sure that this is a small event
of the past and moving on to the much
more important future
so we have a lot of hmm
dana
what do you think happened here well
secretary kerry now climate envoy is
sophisticated enough to know that as
soon as he said that i knew exactly what
he was saying and i think that in some
ways he um remembers he's living in the
days of yore when he was in charge
right and and when everything ran so
smoothly if you recall that um he was
not only throwing president biden under
the bus which is really bad and doing it
overseas under the yacht
imagine imagine though if that had been
a republican right and how the howls
from the democrats would have been how
dare you denigrate a commander-in-chief
when you're on foreign soil this he
actually works for the president
basically oh yeah he had no idea he's
like literally has no idea john kerry
knows what the narrative is
about president biden not being in the
loop but not only that but he threw
lincoln
and sullivan under the bus as well and
you know what maybe he thinks it wasn't
handled well and maybe he raised that at
in the situation room and nobody paid
attention to him but
he it does seem that he knew what he was
doing then he tried to sort of backtrack
he's like well of course you know he
really wants everything to be fine and
it does sound like things are fine now
working out with the french but i have a
feeling that he knew exactly what he was
doing what do you think of that judge
well i absolutely agree with all the
points that you've made and i and i i
think it's interesting the way kerry
starts he says he asked me what's the
situation why would he be asking the
climate envoy what the situation is why
wouldn't he be calling up blinking and
saying to blinken what the heck is going
on with france they canceled the gala
they pulled out two ambassadors what's
going on no he doesn't do that so i
think dana's right on the money i think
it's like the days of yore when he was
secretary of state and i also think that
uh
there's he knew what was going to happen
because all of us now go back to what
was the same thing with the generals
when he said well you know he didn't
remember maybe they said it
and so he's kind of conjuring up an idea
a narrative of his fitness for office
but that's just the way i see it and
that's why i asked you um i want to play
this uh stop from jen saki today in the
press briefing room
you said this this president's first
love is foreign policy so why doesn't he
know about these things in real time of
course he knew about the french being
displeased about let me finish literally
peter i would encourage you to ask john
kerry specifically about the context of
his comments the president
and the former secretary are also good
friends uh he relies on his counsel uh
and as he does as many members of his
national security team but that
certainly is not what he was intending
to convey
so greg what i thought was interesting
about this first of all that obviously
was not what she wanted to be talking
about but jensaki comes from carrie
world she doesn't come from biden world
so what did you think of her defense
well she had no defense she she had
that's why she had to spin i think
the spinning will be joe biden wasn't
aware of it so again it's not his fault
so now his profound ignorance and
possible confusion in this job is his
shield against criticism hey it's
grandpa joe he didn't know
i think that the dems like it this way
the less he knows the better because he
really was elected
to be to be kind of a shell for a whole
other group of democrats right he was
the trojan horse
and it raises the question what else
does joe not know and when did he not
know it
get that
no got it
she just didn't like it she just didn't
like it when did he not know and when
did he not know it he never knew he
never knew no but that's that's the
funny part yes
that's been his mo plausible deniability
right and even the french know i think
when kerry said i didn't didn't really
get it the friend said hey you know
you're ready probably didn't get it and
it takes the sting out of them losing
that deal and you know john kerry
thought he should have been president
you know kerry was in the senate with
joe biden joe biden was always a joke in
the senate carrie thinks like listen
this guy just doesn't know here and it
slipped and he did throw him under the
yacht but this is the biggest
alliance or military development in the
pacific for decades this new alliance we
have with the australians and the
british against the chinese if biden
didn't know about that and the
implications about that that is pretty
scary we not only gave the australian
submarines we gave them
mid-range missiles that can hit the
chinese mainland hit all their shipping
lanes and china can't do anything about
it they're out of range so the chinese
are humiliated they're panicking and
that's why they're lashing out against
taiwan to prop up the regime
domestically but you know they're
they're up you know what's creek you
know jessica can i repeat my joke again
so it gets clipped and people see how
brilliant it is
i think it raises a question what does
joe not know and when did he not know it
do you like it now judge yeah it works
okay thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else